こんにちははじめ佐々ですようやくしゃべることができるようになったような気がする
ので話させていただきます
態度に貼る通りあの日砂流という迷惑給油中ばっていうのが youtube って
いつもあんなんですけどそういう方がいらっしゃいまして
ネットだと結構話題になってたんですよなんですけどもうちょっと理由がありまして僕
1歳あの
今もノータッチ虫毛嚢たついて完全シカトでいきましょうっていう事務所の方との相談
の方向の事
ずーっともうムソン沿いないものとする一点張りでずっときたんですけども
改めてちょっとお話しさせていただきたいと思います
なぜ話をするかと言いますとすごい twitter とかでファンの方とか
視聴者のみ
なさんに何か大丈夫とか心配ですというのはたくさん来て僕もいろいろ返事したかった
んですけどもうちょっと今から話すんですけども理由があって絶対それ答えないように
してました
ご心配おかけして本当にすいませんでしたご心配ありがとうございますででちょっと
心配された方がとても多かったので
実際に何があったのかとかそういうのはちゃんとあの改めて説明しなきゃなと思って
今回動画を撮らせて頂いております
また普通に注意喚起ですこういうことしちゃダメだって言うという意味で順を追って
説明しますがまずヘ砂流という人間がどんな人間かといいますと
僕は全く知らなかったです興味はなかったんですけども音が良く聞く話によるとその
ユーチューバーさんに直接凸してコラボしてくださいってこう迫ってくるみたいなこと
をされてる方だってぐらいの話で聞いてなんですけど
もまあその標的が僕になったっていう話ですはい
うちにも来ましたそれもかなり長い期間
まあまあの粒チャーハンつつんですけどちょっと謎を紐解いて説明していきましょう
なぜ僕がそういう事件があった後
厚み僕はもう完全にとってされました無理カメラを回されてメントスとコーラを買って
押し付けられてやめてくださいやめてくださいと言ったんですけども本当
版6で強制的に肩まで入れられるくらいケッ
効果劇的な感じで来られてめっちゃ強く買って拒否したんですけども深夜の11時とか
な
ca の11時くらいにめちゃくちゃ大声で近所で叫ばれてすごく嫌な思いをしました
所持あ僕キレてましたただ何でそこで僕騒いで何か
怒りの動画を出したりツイッターでやめろーとか何にも言わなかったかと言いますと
その彼の目的がどう見ても by 年
なんですよ売名行為これはもちろんぼくみんなにかして一緒に動画とれてそれをアップ
したらもちろん伸びますし
水野無理やりがあることを知ったらさぁ皆も気になったでしょ手書きにあった人は多い
と思うんですよ知らなかった人ごめんなさいそういうことがあったんです
強制的に動画撮られてもうでも盗られました無理やりでそれで僕がその取られた瞬間
取られましたとか何か
光の何かを言うと向こうの売名行為のサポート
僕が言うと高さのヘ砂流さん毛ず皆さんの知名度を上げるためのお手伝いに過ぎないな
と思いましてあのねあの本田こういうことがないとこのまま一切無視しようかなと思っ
て3つ入っちゃったんですよ
どんな毛強い多いしたかもうケッ
こう普通にねぇ
鬱になるぐらい嫌でした外に出るのが本番のチラシを致しますもちろんちゃ話すんです
けど結構精神的に嫌なことをされて辛かったんですけどもなんとか彼の思い通りにさせ
たくないなっていう思いでぐっと腕に堪えながら皆さんの大丈夫得ずまで優雅切ってる
けど大丈夫という心配のメッセージも無視して一人で殻にこもって頑張っておりました
という話でございます
入っている
予約話せるんですけどまぁ今回なんかいろいろあったみたいでだいぶテレビニュースに
なってますね
テレビとかでニュースで大々的に報道されたらもう by 面を何もないなと思いまし
てまぁを持して説明させていただきます
何をされたかそして僕がどういう思いをしたのかそして何を思ったのか
まあ僕にされたことわざ迷惑行為ですねちなみにどんなが出されたかと言いますとあの
簡単に
と僕の家の近くのコンビニにずーっと張り込み
されていました応用さなんですけども一致を見てる限り1週間くらいかな
1週間でずーっと張り込みしてましたこれに会社も本当コンビニの命理由でもあるんで
僕みんな周りに結構人がいるんでみんなで情報共有してへメニューがいいましたって
いう話が出たらもうみんなで部屋から出ない良好っていうそれだけです
いってねだいたいも1週間でない家から出れなかったですね
貧しくキラのでそもそもてないんですけどのコンビニに買い物に行くとかいう気軽な
買い物を一切禁止で完全に閉鎖空間にいさせていただきました
結構ストレスでしたなんかさんに張り込みしてなんかもう1週間も来なかったら諦めて
帰ったりもしてたらしいんですけども私は
2と帰って来てずっと張り込みどっか行って帰って来て張り込み
みたいなことをもっと前からわかんないも全然覚えてないんですけども相当長い期間さ
れてたみたいです本当に迷惑でしたすみませんで全部無効の無許可で取らねえてゆるの
であの使わせていただきますどうぞ
始め
古いはじめえっこれが家の前で吠えてた動画ですねて来34回くらい家の前で相当
でかい声で叫んでました
バッチリ聞こえました僕これ何が嫌かっていうとあの僕ももちろん嫌なんですけども禁
ずの方々に迷惑かけるのだけが本当に嫌で結構警察の方にもご連絡させていただいたん
ですよしっ連携
組んで何かたっすぐ出れるような準備をしているもう万全な状態をしてたんですけども
こういう舞妓とすり抜けられていい感じにすり抜けでずっと滞在させられてましたって
いう感じですねあの他の方がどんなことされたのかわかりませんけど僕がされたらの
こんな感じで結構今はこう冷静に喋ってるんですけども結構イライラムカムカしても
ずるいですよねそのカメラを向けてさあ
をラーってやってこっちを後年かいったくなっちゃうんですけど入っペットこっちが
悪くなるんで向かう方とか入れてきてなんかすごい暴力かわかんない絶妙な事を知って
きて勝手にトラベル訳なんですか
このストレスは計り知れますかであったことも皆に幸言えない無効の場合命だけは絶対
させたくないかという太平らの心苦しい日々を送っておりますってこちらは実際にとっ
てされた動画ですはい
あるおかしいですよねあれおかしいですよね警察呼んでねー
メントスコーラだけお願いしますよ
まあ深夜-10地図に町大出うわぁって叫んでたんでなんか自分のことよりその近所の
人にそういうメイク濃いされるのが本当に本当に腹たってあの正直チェックやみました
ねやもう僕から言えることは特にないです
誰がどう見てもやってはいけないことだということは分かると思いますし
いや俺のほうね
何がつらかったかっていうとこうやってで言えなかったことですね
どこがわかんないとだったらもう同等と動画でこういう人がいましただけじゃねーって
いうんですけど相手がもう場合に目的ということをやられてるんだったら僕はもう
何が何でも絶対反応しないなと思って
絶対と釣られないように気をつけてるんですけども
本当に絶妙なタイミングの悪さで初
合わせてしまってみて取られてしまったというお話でございますそいつがいるいないよ
ずっと気にしなきゃいけないっていうその精神状態も嫌だし家の前で叫ばれている動画
を家庭ネットに出される感覚もすごいやだった
はいということがありました本当に心配された皆様
何も言えずに申し訳ありませんでした今後絶対こういうこと真似してする人が出てくる
と思うんですけども僕は断じて z
反応しませんそれが向こうの目的なんだからビビるぐらい速い速度で警察の方と連携さ
せていただいて動かせていただきます
もう実はバッチリ動いておりますはいってゆーめーや
不幸会がありましたね何か改めて動画にすることでもないかなと思ったんですけども
応えたいときに今なってるんで
じゃあも俺もこの溜まってるをゆゆ4巻ねと思って今言わせていただきました boku
no あのストレス発散動画ですパン的に考えると明らかなの迷惑行為なんで絶対
こんなことしちゃダメだなって分かると思うんですけどもそれでも真似しちゃう人が
出るかも知れ
の絶対やめておきましょうなんかうん大体言いたいことは言えたかな
まあこれだけじゃないっすよ本当はもっといろんなことされてましたよなんかわけ
わかんない手紙カップに入れられたり金に玄関でピンポンされてめっちゃ大声で叫ばれ
たりとか証拠として登ってないんですけど本当にもっといろんなことされてるんです
けどなぁひとまず超えていえてちょっとスッキリしておりますマジではこう言う
この時期だからつにウイルス運んでる可能性とかまでめちゃくちゃ危険なんですねやっ
ていることがはい
とっても嫌でした
まぁ今までできるんだけどねぇまぁ全然できるんですけども当時はめちゃくちゃ
落ち込んでた c twitter とか全然俺の心わかんなかった所ば感ないでしょ
出さないようにしてたの出さないようにしてたんですけどめっちゃくちゃウッズになり
かけてください結構気が病んでてイライラしてた時が多かったんです
ボカフェイス今元気なので水は遠いボタンしないようにしましょう
じゃん
[音楽]
ブーブー
ぱっちょ